here at the Institute and I'd like to
welcome you to this workshop on
Federated and Collaborative Learning
which has been organized as part of the
process of writing a proposal for a full
semester program on the same topic
and I'd like to thank the organizers
John duchy nikahab Peter who's Virginia
Smith
for putting together a great program so
let's let's give them some flaws
and I'd like to cover a few logistics
for the coming week so so there is food
and coffee outside before the first talk
and between talks on both the days
but there is no lunch so that gives you
an opportunity to explore all the the
exciting and ever-changing restaurants
on the south side of Campus
we do ask that you leave food and coffee
outside the auditorium to help keep it
as clean as it is and and when you do go
outside there's this there are some nice
lockers on the other side of the
building where you can just dump your
stuff on the way out which I like using
a lot
uh so our videographer Omid far will
help you set up your talk if you have
any kind of technical difficulties
please uh please ask him for help
and I want to give a special thanks to
our uh events team Elizabeth and Ashley
who organized all the logistics for this
Workshop including accommodation for out
of town visitors and so let's give them
a round of applause
and uh now I will hand it over to uh
Ginger who say a few things about the
workshop
thank you
I think you said it's gonna be three
minutes and that was exactly exactly a
three minute and
uh so yeah
real today for for shop on Federated and
Collaborative Learning
um along with you know the other
organizers
um John Nika Peter Maddie and Kunal I
want to give a very very brief
introduction just to set the stage for
you know the motivation of Federated and
Collaborative Learning very generally so
if you're thinking about you know
exciting applications of machine
learning right now you might be thinking
about something like chat Bots or maybe
an adjacent application something like
speech recognition or medical
applications of machine learning or
Smart Homes or smart cities crucially
all of these applications rely on data
so where is this machine learning data
coming from it's not coming from just a
single mobile phone user or a single
patient or a single hospital or a single
sensor it's coming from multiple users
multiple patients possibly split across
multiple organizations and entire
networks of sensors so in Federated
learning the idea very broadly is rather
than moving all of that data to one
central location trying to to push as
much of the machine learning workflow to
the edge as possible and there can be
nice benefits for doing this this can
help to reduce the strain on the network
there can be possible privacy and
security advantages for not moving as
much raw data across the network
and this has been something that has
been deployed in practice at a smaller
scale this has been used for cross Silo
applications of Federated learning like
learning tumor detection models without
sharing raw patient data and this has
been used for applications like learning
mobile learning prediction tasks in
Mobile keyboards without collecting raw
text information
but there are a number of challenges
that this new paradigm presents so you
know at its heart it's really solving a
distributed learning problem right
um and whereas you know communication is
is always a known bottleneck in
distributed learning here communication
can be very very expensive so you might
have massive slow unreliable Networks
you are not sharing the raw data but
there's obviously still privacy concerns
with sharing information across the
network and with learning a model that's
possibly deployed at the edge and there
can be you know uh difficult issues in
dealing with the fact that the data
might differ across each of these
devices or across the data silos so
there might be issues with statistical
heterogeneity and at a lower level if
you're learning across these devices
there can also be issues with
differences in the underlying Hardware
or connectivity that can also affect how
capable each of the devices are at
participating in this training procedure
I want to also take a step back and talk
about sort of a bigger picture here
which is the idea of Collaborative
Learning uh so more broadly Federated
learning is maybe one example of a much
broader idea which is the the idea of
having to learn across multiple sources
and stakeholders and you can imagine
many such applications of this
especially as you know machine learning
applications are trying to leverage more
and more data often we have to think
about processing and aggregating data
from multiple sources and across
multiple stakeholders and this presents
many interesting new challenges for
example thinking about how to
incentivize participation in these data
sharing schemes
how to better enable privacy and
security and trustworthy learning
schemes how to effectively model these
heterogeneous data sources
so I'm not going to talk too much more
about this because one of the goals of
the workshop I think will be to dive a
little bit deeper into these broader
definitions of Federated learning and
think more about what we mean as a field
by these terms Federated and
Collaborative Learning but I want to
briefly say why we're having this
Workshop why are we you know doing this
in the context of the Simon's Institute
which we're very fortunate to be working
with so I you know one I think crucial
aspect here is just having a need for
more foundational science there are an
increasing number of deployments of
Federated and Collaborative Learning and
practice but there are still numerous
fundamental questions that remain
and one thing that we're hoping to do uh
you know as as a result of this Workshop
is to develop a little bit more of a
consistent notion of definitions
assumptions and techniques for Federated
Collaborative Learning
um that better reflect real world
deployments
so uh another obvious aspect here and
one reason I'm really I'm really excited
to be with you all today is also just to
Foster community in this emerging area
in particular noting that Federated and
Collaborative Learning draw from a very
very wide range of communities
from you know folks in machine learning
statistics optimization privacy econ
distributed systems and the the work
here really spans industry and Academia
so we're excited to have a lot of
diverse viewpoints here today and and to
help Foster community in this area
very concretely for the workshop some of
the goals
we want to discuss recent advances in
federating Collaborative Learning but
there's also going to be a major focus
on identifying open problems in the
field and discussing a path for tackling
these open theoretical problems in a way
that Bridges theory and practice
in terms of some concrete outcomes so
we're going to be the the talks are are
open to the public we're going to be
recording the talks and live streaming
them uh but we also hope to develop a
collaboratively developed paper that
identifies and lists out some of these
open theoretical problems and the hope
is to use these materials to submit a
proposal for a longer initiative so a
semester-long program at the Simon's
Institute on Federated and Collaborative
Learning
I'm not going to go into too many
details of the the agenda you can find
this on the the website but you know
roughly uh the the workshop is going to
be split into a combination of having
some talks on recent advances in
Federated Collaborative Learning and and
open problems and also some focused
discussion sessions and one thing to
note here is that these talks are are
open to the public the discussion
sessions are meant for you know for
smaller groups so these will be for the
invited participants of the workshop
we also have a dinner tonight so please
do make sure to attend that if you're in
town that's going to be taking place at
gather
okay and uh tomorrow we again have a
nice set of talks and we're also going
to be spending the afternoon uh having
discussion but also splitting into some
working groups to start actually
producing this this white paper on open
problems in the field
a really quick FAQ so the talks are
going to be live streamed and recorded
um and again these talks are open to the
public but the discussion section and
the workshop dinner will be for invited
participants any questions before we go
ahead and get started
we're roughly on time that's great
um so I want to introduce now uh Katrina
Liggett who is a professor in uh at
Hebrew University in the school of
computer science and engineering and is
also the head of the program uh that
looks at the interfaces of Technology
society and networks her research
broadly is in data privacy machine
learning theory algorithmic fairness and
algorithmic Game Theory and she's been
involved in a number of broader efforts
across these communities for example she
in 2021 was the co-chair of alt and a
fork and is currently an Advisory Board
member for the Harvard University open
DP project so we're really fortunate to
have her with us today so let's give
just a a welcome to Katrina
[Applause]
the mic and it's working and
I'll bring up
and then cross our fingers that the
magic happens
but it will shortly we're sure
yes
great so it's great to be here nice to
see you all and thanks for the
invitation I'm going to be talking today
about
some joint work and conversations that
I've been having with Komar shadmi who's
a law scholar at the Hebrew University
and those conversations will form the
basis of a talk that I hope is a good
source of provocations and research
directions
um things at the sort of interface with
Federated learning that I'm particularly
excited about and I hope some of those
might feed into those discussions that
we'll be having over the next couple of
days
um so tomorrow and I are at the Hebrew
University of Jerusalem full disclosure
I also consult for a bubble one day a
week but this is not work you at Google
uh when did I first come in contact with
Federated learning I think it was in
2014.
um I gave a tutorial at nuremps on
machine learning and differential
privacy and afterwards
um Brendan McMahon came up to me and he
basically like in just a couple of
minutes convinced me that like the
future is going to be data on device
compute on device and it was really
clear that he was on to something and he
was really really convinced of it at
that point
um and then it's sort of been for me a
bit in the background and then a couple
of years ago Thomas I mentioned is a law
scholar not a computer scientist started
asking me sort of like what's up with
all this decentralization that's going
on in computer science and like what is
it really doing what is it doing right
um what's the potential there and where
is it falling short and so that sort of
started some conversations for us that
will inform our conversation here today
I'm not actually somebody who has been
working in Federated learning I'm
somebody who's been adjacent to it uh in
my many sort of research interests and
hats I've worked on learning and privacy
and fairness and incentives and all
sorts of things that I think are really
relevant to the FL conversation but I
actually haven't been working NFL and
because of that I suspect that I'm going
to fail to cite your favorite paper and
I just want to apologize right now for
the moment when I do that and invite you
to tell me about it
um I'm here to learn so I this is not in
any way an attempt to be a survey this
is sort of I'm going to tell you a
stylized story that's an attempt
um to highlight where I think there's
some interesting opportunities for work
in some places you may tell me hey I
already solved that problem that's also
great
um but I'm going to try to be a bit
provocative to try to push the
conversation here
um all credit for anything interesting I
might say goes to Tomer I'll credit for
anything wrong I say goes to me all
right with that let's get started so so
for me the conversation with Palmer and
and sort of my thinking about what do we
get from Federation what do we get from
um this sort of decentralization in
learning starts by thinking about well
what do we have
before that what is the centralized
model of machine learning and data use
and what are the things that we're
worried about there
and so for me I tried to split that up
into two rough Columns of things that go
wrong or that are problematic about
centralized machine learning
um and I call them control and
competition even though I have problems
with both of those names but let's just
go through it even though we all know
all these problems because I think this
is a good starting place to understand
maybe what are some of the things that
we can try to do differently or better
with a different architecture so on the
control column we have concerns that you
know you kind of hand over all the data
to some centralized server and then they
do whatever they want to with the data
um and so there are no limits on how it
gets used where it gets used whether it
gets reused whether it gets abused
whether it gets collected for one
purpose and then they decide to do
something else with it entirely whether
the data that litter gets shared or
stolen or sold or spied on
um and there's also the concerns about
what happens from the intentional uses
of the data that the models that you
train and the statistics that you
publish and the synthetic data that you
create all slowly even if you do it
carefully and less slowly if you do it
less carefully link information about
the underlying data another these
concerns that sort of underlie sort of
all of this we have no control over
where that state is going which are
concerns about
the folks whose data is being used
typically don't really have a voice in
how that data is used what gets computed
how those people get categorized as a
result the ways in which their future
opportunities and choices and World
Views and and sort of definition of self
potentially get affected by the
downstream uses of this data the impact
on groups they care about on society so
that's kind of the you know pretty quick
pretty negative story on the left hand
side and then on the right hand side we
have all this sort of competition kinds
of concerns that come up
um typically especially these days we
think about machine learning beating
pretty big scale in terms of compute in
terms of the amount of data that it
requires in terms of the engineering
expertise that it requires and there
aren't that many organizations that are
up to the task and so we already kind of
narrowed the field into in terms of who
can be in this space and then we have
this phenomena where more data tends to
be get better models tends to be get
more data and so we end up with sort of
Rich get richer phenomena in the space
we have data then concentrating in the
hands of a few as a result we have
economic power and knowledge value
concentrating in the hands of a few and
it becomes difficult to break into this
Market
um potentially stifling you know great
new innovations that could be based on
our Collective data the uses of the data
and potentially unaligned with the
interests of the individuals from whom
that data derives potentially end up
unaligned with the interests of the
groups they belong to with society and
we also ended up in a situation where
maybe we're under using data as well
data becomes unavailable potentially for
societally beneficial uses or for sort
of new innovation and there's sort of
limited space to get collaborative and
creative when we have the data style it
away in this space and for me this is
where the story starts and then
in 2015 we see this uh really I think
insightful paper uh choker inch
smartikov
um where they basically say all of that
really well in just a couple of
sentences I like grabbed sentences from
the paper because they talk about you
know the the privacy issues the fact
that the the data can be kept
indefinitely the users have no choice
about deletion the purpose is the fact
that there could be subpoenas
surveillance that was my left hand side
and then on the right hand side they
talk about the Giants Monopoly on big
data and the fact that this results in a
monopoly on the AI models and the
concerns about the fact that users may
not actually be benefiting from these
models that get created
so they told that story really well
already at that point and then they said
maybe we could do something different
in this dream well what if the Dana
never had to leave the control of those
who generate or own it what if our
Collective data Were Somehow more widely
accessible for a range of use cases and
they made a proposal
that really drives in this direction
so in this paper I'm just pulling quotes
from the paper because I think it tells
exactly the story that we want to we
want to look at at this point in this
paper we design Implement and evaluate a
practical system that enables multiple
parties to jointly learn an accurate
neural network model it was focused on
deep learning uh for a given objective
without sharing their input data sets
our system lets participants train
independently on their own data sets and
selectively share small subsets of their
model's key parameters during training
all of a sudden you notice okay we got
decentralized we've got individuals
having autonomy and choice and they were
choosing to participate they're going to
actively share each participant fully
controls which gradients to share and
how often each participant downloads a
subset of the parameters from the server
and uses them to update his local model
so individuals all of a sudden became
active they opted into participating in
the in the in the computation they are
choosing what to share what to use what
to build and on top of it they suggest
using differential privacy to protect
the option
so the really like
looked at our list of concerns and dug
into a whole bunch of them really really
effectively and for me this is sort of
the start of the story it's like wow we
had all these problems maybe maybe we
can really like hit a bunch of them with
this new architecture
and then of course
um we have this paper that
coins the term side of rated learning
and I think really kicks off this
amazing sort of flurry of work that
sorry the Federated in Federated
learning that we've seen in the past
five or so years
and so there
as we all know and as Virginia already
told us we shift the model a bit and
this is the cartoon that I'm going to
use for the shifted model instead of all
sort of shipping our data off to some
centralized server that does its
computations now we live in a world in
which there's going to be interaction
and we're going to be sort of handing
back and forth you know models and model
updates you know they're they're you
know sort of variants on the particulars
but there's going to be some degree of
back and forth of interaction and
individuals are going to be not shipping
over their entire data Maybe
um but something that is supposedly more
sort of compact and takes more of the
form of of an update there's sort of two
threads as Virginia alluded to in this
literature there's more of this
cross-device model which is the the idea
that we have a bunch of people's iPhones
that are together uh training a model
um and then there's the cross Silo
version which is like we have a bunch of
hospitals that have data
um
they have similarities they have
differences I'm going to focus more on
Cross device and what I talk about today
but I will point to cross Silo a couple
of times as we go along
and I think I think there's
interesting challenges in both
okay
so
what's the Hope here the hope is that
this new architecture gives us the
opportunity to reduce the information
that's shared
to involve individuals actively somehow
in the process selecting the
computations and carrying out the
computations to allow new modes of
collaboration
and potentially open up broader
uses of the data and a broader set of
users of the data okay so that's the set
of opportunities that I want to pull out
that we hope we might get from Federated
learning and basically for the rest of
our time together what I want to do is
use these opportunities
as sort of the structure for our
conversation
and I want to look at them critically
and think about where are we now in
terms of Federated learning in terms of
the theory in terms of the practice uh
with resp in with respect to each of
these opportunities
what where is the progress been where
are people thinking about these issues
so far and where are the opportunities
what haven't we done yet I remember are
there maybe some interesting questions
waiting for us there
so that's the plan okay so first the
opportunity to reduce the information
that's leaked we had all of those issues
about you know data going places and
doing stuff that we didn't want it to do
and so the question is you know is
Federated learning gonna solve this
problem for us and this sort of first
answer is well okay we know there's a
problem with machine learning
potentially if we're not careful if we
don't do something explicit to protect
privacy we know that trade machine
learning models even if they kind of
look Okay can potentially
encode sensitive data from the from the
training
and it turns out as you all know and as
many of you have helped highlight we
have the same problems potentially with
Federated learning
um those gradients even if they don't
look like the data can certainly be
revealing and maybe we'll hear more
explicitly about some of that work so
we've had you know a lot of interest in
making it clear I think that there's a
problem if you don't do something else
and we've also had a lot of beautiful
work really an explosion of work on
addressing the problem head-on so
introducing differential privacy is a
constraint for Federated learning
um so many papers I did not even attempt
to like sample from the from them all
and this is yielded I think a lot
um not just on the sort of practical
side in the sense that actually we see
differential privacy actually being
Incorporated in some large-scale federal
Federated learning deployments like
gboard and the Apple equivalent all
these things but also there's been
interesting stuff going on on the sort
of Foundations in the mathematical side
we see new models coming out like the
shuffle model we see cool new
amplification tools which I view as sort
of a more General contribution to the
sort of state of the field really
beautiful math coming out as a result of
sort of try to tackle this problem head
on and we also have sort of progress in
the sense that at this point I think
some people really do know that
Federated learning on its own
doesn't solve privacy
which is also progress that I think we
should you know be happy with
um
but there's room to do more
um yes there are more problems on DP
Federated learning specific technical
questions that are interesting but there
are other things that I think maybe
are a little less obvious how we tackle
them like what is an Epsilon of two per
day mean
so for those of you who are not in the
DP literature Epsilon is the sort of
privacy parameter you know measuring how
much privacy is lost and if you do
multiple computations with differential
privacy guarantees those privacy losses
add up in a formal mathematical sense
and so when we have a deployment of
Federated learning with the differential
privacy guarantee that has a privacy
loss of some value to per day
me
um I think we need to do some work
towards well maybe giving better
guarantees but also trying to understand
does that mean something
um because I don't really think that we
have something
convincing enough to say there
and also also I think many of the other
things that make the Federated setting
exciting and the challenges there will
interact in interesting ways with
privacy that haven't yet fully been
explored or maybe they haven't I just
don't know about it so that's where
you're going to tell me so things like
um if we're interested really in
increasing individuals autonomy or
flexibility in choosing which
computations they're going to engage in
and with whom to compute you know who do
I want to train my models with then we
have to ask well in that process of
finding your tribe and deciding together
what to compute what do you all reveal
to each other and to the public and to
any sort of central coordinator who's
helping you in that process
um if we're gonna do group deliberation
on what to compute or who to allow to
use or kill a collective data
we have to think about the privacy
concerns about that prop in that process
I I think there's more work to be done
in thinking about if we want Federated
learning to be more of an open framework
um how do we structure that to you know
sort of have the most favorable trust
model possible
um and how can we reduce Reliance
potentially on the centralized curator
where we're currently all talking with
this one
um this one sort of Monolithic entity
and you know so the obvious Direction
here is to sort of combine privacy with
more security tools
so I think
there are questions here that are ready
to develop and dig into
um next up I the opportunity for active
individual participation in selecting
the computations
so
is this happening today
I think in the cross Silo model where a
bunch of hospitals are getting together
and saying yeah I want to train a model
to detect this type of tumor oh yeah you
do too cool let's do that together
because neither of us has enough data
yes they are actively involved in
deciding what they want to compute and
with whom they want to compute it great
are we
actively involves
um in deciding what we want to compute
on our iPhones and our Android devices
and and thinking about like what we want
to compute as a society not so much do
most people even know they're
participating in Federated learning
right now
so much
um and as the literature is observed
many individuals who are participating
in Federated learning may actually not
be benefiting from the trained models
because those trained models may not
actually be good for their data
distribution
and so what's been done here
there are a number of threads of work
that I think are really promising
um so one of these lines of work is sort
of personalization of the results of
Federated learning so we train a you
know a big General sort of average-y
kind of model together and then you
locally maybe do some adaptation there
are a number of sort of techniques that
get used for this but try to address the
fact that oh we have some heterogeneity
in our data distributions maybe we're
not all going to be happy with the same
model maybe there's something we can do
about that
um we also have people trying to
understand just sort of more inherently
what is the role that collaboration
plays in learning under various sort of
assumptions about uh the tasks and the
distributions and we also have people
thinking about fairness explicitly
saying you know we want to set as an
explicit objective that if we're going
to develop a joint model that we care
about in some sense the vector of
qualities that this has on various
people's you know distributions and
we're going to impose some you know
objectives or constraints on various
Notions of fairness there
we also have people who are doing really
interesting work on incentivizing
participation saying hey if you are
going to be participating in Federated
learning maybe we ought to have designed
the system so you're better off
participating than not or maybe we
should design the system to give even
stronger guarantees than that how can we
think about that how should we
articulate the choices that are
available to individuals there
um and so I think those are really great
starts but they're just starts
um there's more work to do I think of
these flavors
one sort of comment that maybe rhymes
with some of the things that Virginia
was saying at the beginning is that the
sort of observation or the problem that
one universal model may not be good for
everybody when our data is heterogeneous
that's not a Federated learning problem
that's a you know heterogeneous data a
problem
but it's got lots of interesting
questions around it so okay let's
Embrace those if we're talking about
Federated learning but it's good to
remind ourselves that there was nothing
sort of inherently Federated about those
flavors of questions
um I definitely think there's room to
think uh more about fairness and weather
fairness is exactly the right concept
here
um I wonder whether there's more room to
think about doing more things locally
and I just questioned sort of whether or
not the literature has been reluctant to
go there in part because it
conflicts with the narrative in some
sense like the narrative around
Federated learning is hey it's unlocking
this ability to use the sensitive data
and if the answer is and actually a lot
of the time we don't want to lock it we
just want to keep it on device it's a
little disappointing
um but if that's the right answer you
know we should be open to it and I think
that there's this also sort of opens up
I think a space to think about
problems
that occur anytime you take a
complicated
situation where there are trade-offs and
conflicts and the way you solve it is
give individual people more control and
responsibility because what happens
often is you give people control and
responsibility in an unreasonable way
where they have bad choices and can't
possibly make them or they're
meaningless and so I'm saying maybe
Federated learning is letting us give
more control to individuals but I think
also you have to pair that with work
that's incredibly critical of giving
more control to individuals because it
can be done very wrong and also think
about maybe can more control the
individuals doesn't mean I literally
turn the knobs on my iPhone to decide
you know which computations I
participate in with which parameters but
maybe rather there are proxies that make
these decisions on my behalf and what
can that look like and what questions
does that raise
um already in this um many authored 2021
survey around Federated learning a lot
of I think key questions here were
raised that I think the the literature
hasn't dug into quite yet who decides
what's the model be trained what's the
algorithm to use what hyper parameters
who's making these decisions
and the paper says well you're kind of
going to need a central Authority this
but also then hence or maybe not
um maybe those decisions could be taken
by whoever says hey let's let's all
learn this thing or maybe those
decisions could be taken somehow
collaboratively and I think those lead
exactly to the next sort of set of top
challenges and opportunities where I
think there's there's space to do some
really interesting work
um so has this sort of Federated model
LED
entities to collaborate in sort of
interesting new configurations again in
the cross Silo world I think the answer
is yes hospitals that could not
previously learn together are now
learning together and it's great
in the cross device setting I think the
answer is no I am not collaboratively
learning models with people who are
similar to me in some cool new way that
is not happening
um but maybe it could be
um maybe
it is going to require some rethinking
the system though because right now the
system is not driven to sort of align
with the interests of individuals or
groups of society
okay so yes we're seeing progress
there's also some of this work that I
was alluding to before that has this
sort of flavor of helping people as part
of the Federated learning find their
tribe so acknowledges that there's
heterogeneity and data distributions and
says hey maybe actually want to take
that into account maybe we want to train
a centralized model and then you want to
sort of update that locally with some
subset of people who have similar data
distributions to you maybe you want to
as part of this you know process
discover who it is who has similar
distributions to you
um I think there's a huge amount of
potential in this space that's as of yet
and these are not fully tapped and it
gets interesting because you cross it
with privacy
um you start to think about okay so how
do I do this process of discovery of you
know and sort of deciding together
potentially what we want to to learn and
there's nice work that says that these
combinations these hybrids actually have
benefits if you're caring about privacy
so doing a combination of sort of
centralized learning and local learning
can actually be good because you don't
have to pay for privacy and the local
learning part of things
um and so that there's sort of an
interesting
um sort of Dimension there to the design
space
but I think there's an opportunity to
take a more radical Focus on the
interests and needs of the participants
in the learning and to think about this
question of how individuals can
collectively discover the value in their
Collective data that may not be apparent
individually maybe there are interesting
ways in which our data is similar and
which it is different from each other
that has value that has interest how can
we discover that together in a way that
respects our privacy I think it's a very
fundamental question that I feel there's
there's room for
um
we also have these really interesting
tensions and trade-offs questions that I
think we can dig into
so if we're in a situation where for
example we have some privacy budget
we're not going to be able to do all the
computations
we have to think together somehow about
which computations we're going to do and
with which pieces of the budget and
maybe our incentives and interest in
this are not fully aligned maybe you're
harmed differently or you benefit
differently from different computations
than I do how do we build the systems
that help us navigate these types of
tensions and trade-offs
and the uh this these questions manifest
I think of many different sort of scales
of the the problem whether it's you know
hospitals trying to decide together what
to compute whether it's totally
non-federated as the U.S census deciding
what what computations to to do on their
data
um but also gets really rich and
interesting when we potentially have
individuals
um who are engaging in this negotiation
um we have questions about
how do we let people in a privacy sort
of respectful way
form these coalitions uh what is the
curator learn about people from the ways
in which the coalitions are formed if
there's a curator involved when and why
do we even need the central curator what
are the ways in which we can move to
Alternative trust models
and then
finally opportunity for wider use of
data
um a new market entrance how do we sort
of address these more competition
oriented questions so what's the state
of the art
so my take
is the reality on competition is not
super great
um at least in the cross-device world as
far as I can tell for iterated learning
is mainly deployed by a small number of
very large companies
um they have closed proprietary
infrastructure that is tied to devices
to operating systems to apps that sort
of already before we came along to think
about FL have massive Market power and
others cannot use this infrastructure to
access the data in any way
um why don't we see small Market
entrants in the space
um I think it's
you know there are a lot of forces
against it Federated learning requires a
large investment in technology and
scientists like some of you guys
um in compute infrastructure it requires
generally a huge standing audience of
participants like you actually have to
have the people and have access to them
it often piggybacks off of existing
models that were built on huge closed
data sets so if you're not somebody who
already had those
um you're in trouble the Privacy
protections they're great I'm in favor
but they also increase the need for data
and that creates an incumbent Advantage
as well
and then why are these infrastructures
even if they're run by you know big
incumbents why they're not open to new
entrants well why would they be I mean
you can tell like we're worried about
privacy story but also where's the
financial incentive
so
where is the progress again probably
mostly in the cross Silo World we're
getting your sort of New Market entrance
New Opportunities is becoming a theme
um and in this world where we're
thinking about individuals and their
iPhones there's been some progress
various attempts to say like let's try
to generalize this FL framework in
various ways that feel like they could
be hinting towards a world that's a
little bit more open a little bit uh
more flexible in various ways but I
think
there's room to do something much more
radical and ask questions like what
would it look like to build and really
truly open Federated Learning System
that looks more like a data Marketplace
I'm not saying it's a good thing I'm not
saying it's a bad thing I'm thinking of
the interesting questions there what's
the technical infrastructure that it
would require how are you going to deal
with privacy how are you going to deal
with privacy budgets how are you going
to deal with decision making are you
gonna do with pricing and all of the
economic questions that come along here
there's so there's a sort of a really
massive space of questions that you can
ask on the way to trying to make our
Collective data be available as a source
of innovation as a source of insight as
a source of societal benefit okay so I'm
going to return to my cartoon that was
originally about how centralized machine
learning has all these problems and I'm
going to say
well we kind of still have most of these
problems right now
opportunity we like Bravos we like hard
problems so it's good for the people in
this room but yeah we kind of still are
in this world where
individuals don't really see that there
are limits on how their data is being
used and where it goes and
there's sort of a sense in which they
don't really have any voice and what
gets computed and the consequences yeah
we like we we did something like there's
some privacy intervention there that's
it's certainly cutting off off a bit of
this sort of spread and the leakage it's
sort of like
turning down the knob a little bit
and we still kind of have all the
competition problems
so we have lots of problems to solve
still the beginning it seemed like wow
Federated learning we nailed this done
we crossed off all the problems and the
reality is a little bit more complicated
and the reality is a little bit more
complicated also in a bunch of other
ways that I didn't even mention yet so I
want to just touch on a bunch of other
possible challenges that I think offer
interesting research opportunities as
well in this space
um one of them's environmental impact I
haven't heard somebody talking about
this but I hope somebody already is when
you take computations that you would
have been doing on some super efficient
centralized server and instead do them
all these little local devices there's
gotta be some consequences for energy
usage
um has anybody tried to quantify those
um there's also sort of this question
that basically is what Tomer said to me
once she first heard about Federated
learning was like who gives them
permission to borrow my compute
electricity battery and storage for
their interests instead of mine
um which I think it's a fair point
um there's also I think a really valid
concern that in some cases Federated
learning is really explicitly being used
not so much as a protection but as an
excuse to bypass ethical and legal
requirements for opt-in or consent and
sort of privacy issues
um and also there's this sort of you
know yay we're getting to unlock all of
this data but also maybe lessier we're
unlocking a lot of potential on less
desirable uses and impacts if we don't
have
um additional
safeguards in place
there's also concerns which are not
super specific to Federated learning but
I think take on interesting New
Dimensions around why should we believe
the results
um and can we build some better tools to
make the results more verifiable
um to increase trust in the results that
are obtained
um there's also sort of this lurking
concern that as we decentralize this
sort of infrastructure it may become
more challenging or at least there may
become an excuse to do less of the kinds
of auditing and verification that we
might want to do on these kinds of
systems whether it's auditing the
training data itself whether it's
auditing the behavior of the algorithms
I think they're really nice questions
here
um let's go develop distributed privacy
preserving auditing algorithms we can do
it I think we have the tools it's just
we have to realize that it's an
interesting and important question
so the bottom line for me is that
decentralization
is less sort of an immediate yes we
nailed it solution and more of an
invitation
uh to
spend some more time thinking about the
Privacy challenges and questions just to
spend some more time thinking about how
do we increase individual autonomy in
this whole learning process
um to generally think a little bit more
about how we build systems that take
into account the interests and Welfare
of individuals and groups in society
um and maybe to create more sort of
shared infrastructure that can allow for
appropriate levels of data reuse while
being respectful of the the important
privacy considerations
um but maybe they can unlock this data
in new ways that it's not currently uh
that we're not currently seeing
and then I think that this is a good
moment to do this thing that we did
earlier which is to realize a lot of
these questions are actually not super
specific to Federated learning and
sometimes they came up
because Federated learning invited us
to abandon sort of the existing
assumptions in infrastructure these
questions are super relevant in lots of
other spaces where we're not actually
doing Federation we're not actually
doing decentralization
um but Federated learning was more of a
chance to step away from the status quo
and I will
leave you with sort of two sort of
even less technical takeaways
um one of them is that the architectures
that we build have consequences they
have consequences for rights for norms
for wealth for politics for power these
are not the kinds of things we think
about most of us on a day-to-day basis
um but it's maybe worth in these kinds
of contexts where we're doing agenda
setting and we're trying to
um figure out what the big questions are
to recognize that and the other thing
that I wanted to do was share a couple
of sentences that Tomar actually wrote
um
is sort of reflecting on how she views
Federated learning and would she she
kept emphasizing is that Federated
learning is at its core a really sort of
emancipatory radical idea
um and so she wrote Federated learning
suggests a radical opportunity for
data-based agency and self-rule
facilitating individuals agency involves
creating technological and legal
structures that enable individuals and
communities to tell participate in and
create their life stories through data
the this again is not the kind of thing
that any of us know how to say or write
or maybe even think about but I thought
it's a really interesting provocation
it's a very different take on the kinds
of problems that that we're trying to
solve the kinds of things we're trying
to build here and so I will leave with
that and welcome comments questions
Corrections and
[Applause]
yeah
come on somebody has to tell me yourself
one of these problems what have you
already solved all of the problems right
thanks a lot for the talk you made it
seemed like uh for cross Silo we don't
have a lot of the challenges around
people wanting to decide whether or not
they want to participate but the way I
understand it is a bunch of businesses
right coming together and saying there's
a business opportunity for us and the
end users the patients or the customers
of a bank did not have a say in that
process
yeah so so okay thank you let's say that
again because it's a good enough Point
let me say it back to you
um that I sort of
generally was saying in many cases oh
this you know the cross Silo thing is
maybe a little less complicated we've
seen more progress what I should have
said is we are seeing
um I think
more innovation in some sense in terms
of unlocking structures and
opportunities in the cross-silow world
um that's not to say that there aren't
challenges at the level of those
institutions and as you point out that's
not to say that there aren't
problems consequences harms for those
who with to whom the data is associated
which are generally not just the
institutions so absolutely
great Point thank you
thank you yeah nothing
yeah I'm trying to form this into a
question and kind of failing so maybe
part of the question is what's the right
question here but I in this uh view
especially uh I think really
crystallizing that last uh quote that
you have uh for the cross device it's a
view as if you know my device is under
my control and that's a complete policy
I mean my device is not under my control
um and I'm wondering where so maybe
there's two parts here one is where
maybe where is the boundary between me
and you know Google or Apple is it
really between you know what my device
sends a server or is is the boundary
well inside the device uh in related we
talked about a Marketplace one may be
hindrance that I'm wondering if this is
part of a vision is regulatory because
right now there's no Marketplace because
there's only one entity that can
actually
run uh learning on my device right
that's you know if I you know just the
the manufacturer of the device and
that's it
um or and and so maybe in order to if
you really want to realize this
um dream maybe at the end
um
how do you see this here again I'm not
sure what the question is here but I
mean it's uh you know do you see this as
a part of like maybe a regulatory maybe
yes with opening up so any entity can
run uh Federal learning uh on devices
and not just the manufacturer of those
those are great send me questions uh the
first one I think is a beautiful point
which is that like I think the boundary
between self and these large tech
companies is somewhere complicatedly
embedded in the device and yeah it's a
great point the device is not mine I
don't control it
um there's a lot of things that happen
on it that I have no say in and no
awareness of
and I I don't have an answer to the semi
question other than to say yes this is
an important point to acknowledge and
this is these kinds of boundaries are
going to be part of this conversation
and this in the research challenges
going forward I don't know how many
answer there about the the marketplace
question that's exactly sort of the
challenge that I wanted to highlight and
I don't I haven't solved the challenge
um but yes right now the infrastructure
is proprietary
and so so nobody else can come along and
reuse that infrastructure
um and it's for like all the reasons
that I put up on the slide but there's
not a inherent reason why we couldn't
build an alternative
it more open infrastructure
um but in some cases it will either
require the Willing cooperation of large
tech companies or the forced cooperation
of large tech companies yes yeah Donnie
just just a follow-up
you maybe make it sound like as if uh
only Google and apple are doing learning
on uh from Apple devices and decades
multitude of companies who are using
these These are basically platforms
they're not just companies like uber
Facebook all of these companies collect
massive amounts of data and can use the
direct design if they want they can do
it in any way they like and nobody sort
of prohibits them from doing like using
these more privacy preserving they can
run their own servers the apps
can send them whatever data they they
like and and maybe the one way to think
about these companies is providing
making these Technologies available
privacy preserving uh because available
to other companies and potentially even
ideally even even kind of establishing
certain standards for how the data
should be collected and used uh in a
more privacy preserving so it's me I
don't know if it's a yeah it's more of a
common it's a great comment yeah
last question last question
I guess we talked a lot about control
and
I guess already if I look at my phone
there's tons of knobs in there that I
absolutely don't understand I could turn
them but it's not helping me it's not
helping anyone right so I think that
raises the big question of I guess it's
partly a UI problem like I may have some
privacy preferences but there's no way
to easily express them on my phone uh
and I guess this is not just unique to
FL like websites have privacy policies
no one understands them and uh
there's I guess many other places where
similar things happens so I guess are
there good examples of uh
solutions that exist for such complex
URL problems of preference elicitation
that we can look up to
not that I have in mind but I would love
to hear if people think that there are
um but you're right that this is a more
General problem that you know as I try
to allude to that you know control is a
slippery solution in this space because
it's not really that I want to expose
all of the decisions to you and expect
you to make all the decisions and it's
not just a uix kind of a question
although there's certainly a UI ux
component to it there's also this sort
of deeper philosophical question about
what does it mean to give you
appropriate voice and choice and say and
influence and it probably doesn't
literally mean make you make all the
choices
um and that's not inherently a Federated
learning question but it's something
that I think like many of these
questions is brought to the fore because
we kind of told ourselves this story
that as we push the compute out to the
edge that people were becoming
participants rather than subjects
and maybe it's an opportunity to try to
realize that a little bit more but I I
don't have a great answer
[Applause]